Вітаю на уроці геометрії 10-го класу!
Мене звати Владислав Кононенко.
Темою сьогоднішнього уроку є
«Прямокутна система координат у просторі».
Також ми з вами дізнаємось,
як знаходити середину відрізка за
заданими координатами його кінців,
та відстань між двома даними точками.
Тож, перейдемо до нашого першого питання.
Власне, прямокутна система координат.
Прямокутною системою
координат або ж декартовою,
називають три попарно перпендикулярні
прямі зі спільним початком.
Цей початок позначають буквою О,
і називається він початком координат.
Прямі є координатними осями.
Позначають їх буквами X , Y та
Z і називаються вони відповідно:
X-вісь абсцис, Y-вісь
ординат, та Z-вісь аплікат.
Як же найкраще
запам’ятати їх розташування?
Ви дуже добре знайомі з курсу планіметрії
з двовимірною системою координат.
Ви знаєте, що за вертикальний
напрям відповідає вісь Y (вісь ординат),
та  за горизонтальний вісь Х (абсцис).
Власне, який третій вимір додається?
Ви раніше знаходили площу прямокутника,
знаючи його довжину та ширину.
Третім виміром є висота.
Тому ми маємо подивитись на нашу,
знайому нам на площині
декартової системи координат
X та Y,
та подивитись на неї зверху.
Якщо ми станемо на
осі Z та подивимось вниз,
то ми побачимо  дуже знайому  картину,
де Y буде направлений
вертикально, а X – горизонтально.
Прямі, вони перетинаються
попарно і утворюють три площини.
Ці площини називають також
координатними площинами,
позначають їх відповідними
літерами, згідно з прямими,
при перетині яких
утворилися ці площини,
та ось ви можете бачити
їх зображення на слайді.
Площина xOy, xOz  та  zOy.
Форма запису координат.
Форма запису не
змінилася з курсу планіметрії.
Так само у дужках, в
тій самій послідовності,
єдине, що додається третя
координата, власне, апліката.
Як же визначити
координати точки в просторі?
У 2D геометрії ми мали з точки
опустити перпендикуляри на осі координат.
Тоді там, де цей перпендикуляр
перетне певну вісь –
ми і отримували нашу
відповідну координату.
У просторовій геометрії
ми маємо з точки опустити
перпендикулярні
площини до осей координат.
Ви бачите, що координати точки М
на малюнку зображені як M(x; y; z).
Вони утворилися як перетин
площин альфа, бета, гамма.
Це є перпендикулярні площини
до наших осей координат X , Y та Z –
це і будуть координати нашої точки.
Тепер в мене питання
до вас, шановні глядачі.
Ви бачите на слайді точку MХ.
Вкажіть мені, будь ласка,
які з трьох координат,
чи яка з трьох координат,
буде нульовою в цієї точки?
Правильний варіант
відповіді – це номер три.
Дійсно, у точки МХ,
яка знаходиться на осі Х,
нульовими будуть координати Z та Y.
Звідси, ми можемо зробити
певний висновок, що для
того, щоб точки знаходились
на координатній осі,
потрібно, щоб дві інші її
координати були рівними нулю.
Власне, відповідно до точки
Му, нульовими будуть Z та
X , і в точки M Z нульовими
будуть, відповідно, Х та У.
Перейдемо до знаходження
координат середини відрізка.
Задано відрізок з кінцями в точках А та В
і відповідними координатами
( x1, y1, z1 ) та ( x2, y2, z2 ).
Позначимо середину
цього відрізка як точку М.
Тоді координатами середини відрізка
буде півсума відповідних координат кінців
або ж  середнє арифметичне.
Звідси, отримуємо таку формулу –
де абсциса середини, тобто координата
Х, дорівнюватиме півсумі координат А і В,
відповідних теж Х,
та аналогічне для ординат і аплікат.
Формула відстані між
двома заданими точками.
Нехай, задана точка А і В з координатами
(x1, y1, z1 ) та ( x2, y2, z2),
то відстань можна
розрахувати за такою формулою:
корінь із суми квадратів трьох
доданків, де корінь кожен з доданків –
це різниця між відповідними координатами.
Тобто ( x2 – x1 ); (y2-y1); (z2 – z1).
Формула дуже схожа на відстань
між двома точками, з курсу планіметрії.
Власне, додається тільки третій
доданок, доданок з різниці аплікат.
Доводиться формула за
просторовою теоремою Піфагора,
точніше вона на ній базується.
Перейдемо до практичної частини.
Тож, приклад номер один :
визначте, чи належить ця точка
координатній площині чи координатній осі,
у випадку ствердної відповіді, вкажіть її.
Маємо три точки.
Щоб визначити де саме
знаходиться ця точка,
спробуйте починати з
початку відліку, тобто з точки О.
Нехай, ми з вами знаходимось в
точці О і маємо координати (0;0;0;).
Візьмемо нашу першу точку.
Вона має першу координату – один.
Що це означає?
Що ми з нашої точки (0; 0; 0), яка
знаходиться там, рухаємось вздовж осі ОХ,
в додатному напряму на один
відрізок, на одну умовну одиницю.
Далі, маючи координату мінус два,
рухаємось у від’ємному напрямку осі У,
тобто осі ординат і ми
потрапляємо вже… ми
знаходимось в площині
xOy, не на жодній з осей.
Тобто, на ось ми вже не можемо потрапити.
Так, і тепер залишилась наша апліката –
це буде п’ять.
Ми піднімаємось у
вертикальному напрямі на п’ять.
Це буде будь-яка точка простору,
вона не належить жодній з координатних
площин чи координатних осей.
Інший випадок, точка з
координатами (0; 3; 0).
Знов повертаємось на точку
відліку, тобто на точку (0; 0; 0).
По Х та по Z ми нікуди не рухаємось.
Рухаємось ми лише по координаті
У, вона в нас дорівнює три.
У додатному напрямку ми рухаємось
на три одиниці, і ми залишаємось на осі У.
Тому друга точка належить осі У.
Також хочу зауважити,
що це ще може позначати:
кожна координата – це віддаленість
від іншої координатної площини.
Тобто, координата "три"  позначає,
що наша точка віддалена на три
умовні одиниці від площини xOz.
Як це нам допоможе в майбутньому?
Подивимось на третій випадок.
У ньому координати Х дорівнюють нулю.
Це означає, що від площини
yOz віддаленість у нас нуль,
і ми одразу можемо сказати, що
третій випадок належить площині yOz.
Ну і також хочеться додати, що точка два –
точка С (0; 3; 0), оскільки
вона належить осі У,
то вона ще і належить перетину
двох координатних площин.
Власне, yOz , та yOх.
Пропоную ще одне запитання,
на яке ви можете відповісти.
Я називаю координати
точки, а ви скажете мені,
якій же координатній площині
ця точка належатиме.
Тож, є точка В.
Вона має координати 2; 5; 0.
Якій з трьох координатних
площин вона належить?
Правильний варіант відповіді
– координатна площина Х о У.
Оскільки  Z  нашої точки дорівнює нулю,
то і віддаленість площини ХоУ буде нуль.
Переходимо до наступного прикладу.
Приклад номер два.
Тож, позначимо координати точки  D за три
невідомі за (x, y, z), відповідно.
Знаючи формулу середини відрізка,
що дорівнює половині суми відповідних
координат, ми можемо зауважити,
що якщо помножити кожну з координат
середини на два,
то кожна з цих координат,
відповідно, дорівнює
просто сумі координат кінців відрізка.
Скористаємось цим і
запишемо відповідне рівняння.
Тобто, додавши просто координати
точки А та точки D попарно,
тобто x до x, y до y,
та z до z – ми отримаємо
подвоєні координати середини відрізка.
Тобто, подвоєні координати точки М.
Звідси, ми отримаємо відповідне рівняння.
Зверніть увагу на дошку!
Складаємо відповідне рівняння.
Розв’язуючи легко ці
рівняння, отримаємо відповідь.
Координати точки D будуть: -5; 4; та 3.
Переходимо до наступного прикладу.
Увага на екран!
Що таке відстань від точки до прямої?
Відстань від точки до
прямої – це перпендикуляр
з цієї точки до відповідної прямої.
Оскільки координатна площина –
три попарно
перпендикулярні прямі, то вісь
аплікат, тобто вісь Z
(яка вертикально направлена),
буде перпендикулярна
до нашої площини ХоУ.
Тоді, якщо ми опустимо
перпендикуляр з нашої точки М,
нехай він потрапить у точку М1, то він
буде паралельний нашій площині ХоУ.
Ще раз, Z вісь, вона
перпендикулярна до площини ХоУ.
Перпендикуляр до осі Z буде,
відповідно, паралельний до площини ХоУ.
Що нам це дає?
Нам це дає, що точка М1 має таку
саму аплікату, як і наша точка М.
Оскільки вони паралельні площині ХоУ.
Тому координата точки
М1 – третя координата,
буде дорівнювати сім.
Що ж з перших двох координат?
А тут нам допоможе теорія, яку
ми дізналися трішки раніше, власне,
точка М1 знаходиться на осі Z,
вона знаходиться на осі аплікат.
Ми з вами знаємо, що для
того щоб точка знаходилась
на осі, і дві інші координати
мають дорівнювати нулю.
Звідси виходить, що координати
точки М1 будуть 0; 0; та 7.
Тепер залишилось знайти відстань
між двома точками за формулою,
яку ми з вами сьогодні розібрали.
Відповідно, це корінь з суми
квадратів різниць відповідних координат.
Тобто, віднімаємо координату
абсциси точки М від абсциси точки М1 –
це буде: 5 - 0, та відносимо до квадрату.
Додаємо так само з ординатами,
та так само з аплікатами.
Беремо з цього всього корінь.
Робимо арифметичні операції, отримуємо,
що ця відстань дорівнюватиме тринадцяти.
Приклад номер чотири.
Доволі таки популярний тип задач
на знаходження четвертої
вершини паралелограму
або певних його часткових випадків, тобто:
квадрат, ромб, прямокутник і так далі.
Ознайомтесь із задачею.
Пригадуємо властивості паралелограма.
Однією з них є те, що
діагоналі паралелограма
діляться точкою перетину навпіл.
Тобто, якщо наші діагоналі
ВD та AC перетинаються в
точці О, то точка О є
серединою відрізків АС та ВD.
Ми з вами якраз вивчили
формулу знаходження координат
середини відрізка за заданими
координатами його кінців.
Тож, маємо координати точки
А, маємо координати точки С,
беремо їх середнє арифметичне, відповідно,
і знаходимо координати точки О .
Два плюс нуль, поділене
навпіл – це буде один.
Відповідно, мінус один плюс три,
поділене навпіл – це буде також один.
Три плюс три, поділене навпіл – буде три.
Гаразд, знайшли
координати середини відрізка.
Тепер, аналогічно до прикладу два,
ми маємо середину відрізка та
маємо координату одного з його кінців,
тобто координату точки В, ми можемо
з легкістю знайти координату точки D.
Складаємо таке саме рівняння, позначивши
координати точки D x, y та z відповідно.
Маємо, що сума  координат кінців відрізка
дорівнюватиме подвоєним
координатам середини відрізка.
Розв’язуючи рівняння,
ми отримаємо відповідь.
Приклад номер п’ять.
Що таке ромб?
За означенням ромб – це
паралелограм, у якого всі сторони рівні.
Тому, доведення нашої задачі
буде розподілятися на два етапи.
Перший етап відповідатиме
за доведення того,
що ця фігура є паралелограмом.
Другий етап відповідатиме
вже, безпосередньо, за ромб.
Тож, щодо першого етапу, ми
використовуємо ознаку паралелограму,
сформульовану відповідно з властивостей,
які ми вже сьогодні використовували,
а саме – чотирикутник буде паралелограмом,
якщо його діагоналі ділитимуться навпіл.
Тож, маємо діагональ
АС, маємо діагональ ВD.
Давайте знайдемо їх середини.
За середнім арифметичним
координат кінців цих
двох відрізків ми
отримуємо такі дві точки.
Вони співпадають.
Це означає, що діагоналі перетинаються
в точці, яка ділить їх навпіл.
Отже, за ознакою паралелограма
чотирикутник ABCD є паралелограмом.
Другий випадок, друга частина доведення –
це доведення того, що
наш паралелограм є ромбом.
Для цього достатньо довести,
що дві сусідні сторони
паралелограма будуть рівними.
Тож, візьмемо сторони АВ і AD.
За формулою відстані між двома
точками знаходимо їх довжину.
Відповідно, беремо корінь із суми
квадратів різниць відповідних координат.
Так, здається мені, я
чую дзвоник, а це означає,
що треба завершувати і
давати домашнє завдання.
Будь ласка, увага на екран!